Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在进行的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever felt that you're not good enough despite all of your achievements? Like any
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的一小时辅导。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你是否曾经在取得所有成就后，仍然觉得不够好？就像随时
moment someone might find you out and realize you don't belong. That is imposter syndrome and it affects even the most successful people. In today's episode I'll break down exactly why this happens, how it can undermine your confidence and most importantly how you can stop it from holding you back. Whether you're starting a new career or just feeling the pressure to be perfect, imposter syndrome can creep in. But here's the truth, you do belong. And today we're going to talk about why. Stick around for some practical strategies which will help you change the way you think about yourself for good. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Now you might be like, well, of course she doesn't
都有人会揭穿你，意识到你不属于这里。这就是冒名顶替综合症（Imposter Syndrome），它甚至会影响最成功的人。在今天的节目中，我将详细剖析为什么会发生这种情况，它如何削弱你的自信，以及最重要的是，你如何阻止它阻碍你的发展。无论你是开始新的职业生涯，还是仅仅感到必须完美的压力，冒名顶替综合症都可能悄然而至。但事实是，你确实属于这里。今天我们将讨论原因。请留下来，学习一些实用的策略，这将帮助你彻底改变对自己的看法。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。现在你可能会想，当然，她不会
have imposter syndrome, what with being qualified and all. But this does happen for people in all walks of life and all stages of their career. And I can assure you it does crop up for me from time to time. And people across all ages and backgrounds and job roles can experience it and it can be really debilitating. It can of course affect mental health, career growth and personal development. And let's get to grips with it so that you can take control of it rather than vice versa. So what exactly is imposter syndrome? Well, it's like an internal sense that you are not enough or that somehow all of the things you've achieved are not actually down to you. It's down to luck or chance or someone's done you a favour and you haven't earned what you've achieved
有冒名顶替综合症，毕竟她已经获得了资格。但这种情况确实发生在各行各业、处于职业生涯各个阶段的人身上。我可以向你保证，我偶尔也会遇到这种情况。各个年龄段、背景和职位的人都可能经历它，而且它真的非常令人沮丧。它当然会影响心理健康、职业发展和个人成长。让我们来深入了解它，这样你就能掌控它，而不是被它掌控。那么，什么是冒名顶替综合症呢？嗯，这就像是一种内在的感觉，觉得你不够好，或者你取得的所有成就其实都不是因为你。是因为运气、偶然，或者有人帮了你，而你并没有赢得你所取得的成就，
or you don't deserve to be there. It might be that awareness that others are way more qualified or more appropriate to kind of speak or be doing what you're doing. It's basically like a real focus on everything you've got being down to external factors, so things that are not internal, not within your control. And that can leave us feeling quite diminished and quite small. And kind of, of course, if we feel that way, it makes sense that we think that we shouldn't be there. And whatever your job role, perhaps you're working in mental health, perhaps you're working in the psychology field, or perhaps you're doing something completely unrelated. If you kind of find yourself being praised for something, or you're being put forward for a new role, or perhaps even you've got a new
或者你不配待在那里。这可能是一种意识到别人比你更有资格，或者更适合发言或做你正在做的事情的感觉。这基本上就像是真正专注于你所拥有的一切都归因于外部因素，即那些不是内在的、不在你控制范围之内的事情。这会让我们感到相当渺小和卑微。当然，如果我们有这种感觉，我们认为自己不应该待在那里也是合乎逻辑的。无论你的职位是什么，也许你在心理健康领域工作，也许你在心理学领域工作，或者也许你在做一些完全无关的事情。如果你发现自己因为某事受到赞扬，或者被推荐担任新职位，或者甚至你已经有了新
role, you've got a promotion, this can be really common times that that sense of imposter syndrome come in. If you are working in academia, perhaps you've got a book coming out or you've published an important paper and it can kind of strike you at key moments like that. So why does it happen? Well, firstly, it happens because we're human. We've got an awareness of ourselves and where we fit in society, in culture, in our families, in our social circles, in our workplaces. And we've got an awareness of where others fit as well. We can create judgments about ourselves, but we can also create judgments and have opinions of others. Of course, whether we've had experiences in the past where we've been treated nicely, kindly, considerately, compassionately can also impact
职位，获得了晋升，这些都是冒名顶替综合症非常常见的发作时刻。如果你在学术界工作，也许你有一本书要出版，或者你发表了一篇重要的论文，它可能会在这样的关键时刻袭击你。那么为什么会发生这种情况呢？嗯，首先，因为它发生在我们人类身上。我们对自己以及我们在社会、文化、家庭、社交圈、工作场所中的位置有认知。我们也对别人所处的位置有认知。我们可以对自己做出判断，但我们也可以对他人做出判断并持有观点。当然，我们过去是否经历过被友好、善良、体贴、富有同情心地对待，也会影响
on how our self-worth has developed. Perfectionism, fear of failure and high expectations either from yourself and or others can all fuel feelings of inadequacy, of not being enough. And if when you were young you were constantly compared to siblings or others in your class or humiliated for not knowing certain things or not being good enough or others being better, you might find that that perhaps creeps in more as a sense of imposter syndrome when things are going better for you or when you do have kind of the trappings of things going well, like a higher salary or, I don't know, perhaps a nice car or a home that feels comfortable and safe and within your control. It can make you feel, well, who am I to have these things? Because I'm just that kid, you know, did X, Y, and Z and wasn't enough. And,
我们的自我价值感是如何发展的。完美主义、对失败的恐惧以及来自你自己或他人的高期望，都会助长不足感，即觉得“不够好”。如果你在年轻时经常被拿来与兄弟姐妹或班里的其他人比较，或者因为不知道某些事情、不够好或别人比你更好而受到羞辱，你可能会发现，当事情进展顺利，或者当你拥有了诸如高薪、或者我不知道，也许是一辆好车或一个让你感到舒适、安全且在掌控之中的家等成功标志时，这种冒名顶替综合症的感觉可能会更多地悄然而至。这会让你觉得，嗯，我凭什么拥有这些东西？因为我只是那个做过X、Y和Z，却觉得不够好的孩子。而且，
you know, people were laughing at, or my parents didn't even think I was good enough. And so if you're getting that feedback that actually you are credible, you are worthwhile, you are worth listening to, that can tap into the earlier roots that make you perhaps feel that you're not. And of course, there's cultural and societal influences as well. So your gender may come into play here. You know, is it safe for women to achieve? Is it safe for men to achieve? Is it safe for people of different ethnicities, different backgrounds to be in the role that
你知道，人们在嘲笑，或者我的父母甚至认为我不够好。所以，如果你得到的反馈是其实你是可信的、有价值的、值得倾听的，那可能会触及早期的根源，让你觉得你不是。当然，还有文化和社会的影响。所以你的性别可能会在这里发挥作用。你知道，女性取得成就是安全的吗？男性取得成就是安全的吗？不同种族、不同背景的人在你所处的角色中，或者为你所处的角色而奋斗是安全的吗？如果人们公开说，你的背景、你的成长经历、你的财富、你的阶层应该或不应该出现在特定领域，这可能会留下一个小小的阿喀琉斯之踵，一个小小的弱点，在糟糕的日子里，在你情绪低落的日子里，它可能会趁虚而入，让冒名顶替综合症加剧，让你觉得你不够好。那么，冒名顶替综合症的常见迹象是什么？你如何注意到自己是否正在经历它？这就是自我怀疑和负面自我对话
you are in or to be striving for the role that you are in? If people are vocal saying that people of your background, your upbringing, your wealth, your class should or should not be in particular areas, it can leave a little bit of an Achilles heel, a little bit of a weakness that kind of can get in on a bad day, on a day where you're feeling at a low ebb and really give a chance for that imposter syndrome to ramp up and make you feel like you're not enough. So what are the common signs of imposter syndrome and how might you notice if you are experiencing it? So this is where the self-doubt and the negative self-talk
可能会悄然而至的地方。倾听你内心的声音，想象一下如果这是你团队、家庭或朋友圈中的某个人，你会认为他们是一个积极的人，还是认为他们可能是一个倾向于贬低你、并不总是那么友善的人，这会非常有帮助。如果你考虑一直把他们带在身边，在你的肩膀上或脑海里，那是一个真正站在你这边的人吗？还是一个让你在一天、一周、一个月、一年中经历的所有情况下都对自己感觉不好的人？当然，我们知道冒名顶替综合症不仅仅局限于我们的工作、
might creep in. It can be really helpful to just tune in to your inner voice and just imagine if this was someone in your team or in your family or in your friendship circle whether you would consider them to be a positive person or whether you think they might be somebody who tends to put you down and not always be that nice and if you think about carrying them around with you all the time on your shoulder or in your head is that someone that is actually on your side? Or is it someone that's making you feel bad about yourself and all the situations that you might find yourself in throughout the day, throughout the week, throughout the month, throughout the year? Of course, what we know is encoster syndrome is not just linked or limited to our work,
教育环境。它可能出现在朋友圈中。它可能出现在家庭圈中。如果你是父母，相信我，它也可能出现在那里，让你觉得，哦，天哪，我怎么够老或经验丰富到可以成为那个必须知道答案的人？我最近和孩子们在伦敦，一手牵一个，我们在地铁里穿行。这让我产生了一种感觉，我当时想，哦，这怎么会是我的工作？我怎么会是那个负责的人？我怎么会是那个看着各种地铁地图并计算去哪里的人？肯定有比我更有经验、更有能力
our education settings. It can crop up in friendship circles. It can crop up in family circles. If you're a parent, it can crop up there, believe me, making you think, oh, wow, how am I old enough or experienced enough to be the one that has to know the answers for this? I was in London recently with my children, one in each hand as we were navigating our way through the tube. And it just kind of made me, I had this moment of, oh, how is this my job? How am I the one that's in charge? How am I the one that is looking at all the kind of tube maps and working out where to go? There's surely someone that is far more experienced and far more capable
而且作为父母比我更有趣的人来做这件事。所以它不仅仅出现在我们的职业生活中。你可能会发现你在低估自己的成就。所以，如果你做了一些很酷、很大或新的事情，比如做了一个演讲，或者得到了一个新的工作机会，或者甚至只是，你知道，出色地完成了你的旅行，带着孩子去了伦敦，你知道，你可能会低估这些成就。你可能会想，嗯，你知道，任何人都能做到，或者申请那份工作的人不够多，所以，你知道，可供选择的人更少，或者，你知道，这不是真正的考验，因为火车都准时运行。你知道，你可能会用一些事情来低估你做得很好、你坚持住了、你得到了一个好结果的事实。
and maybe more fun as a parent than me for doing this. So it doesn't just crop up for our professional lives. You might find that you're undervaluing your achievements. So if you've done something cool or big or new, like a presentation or got a new job offer, or maybe even just, you know, smashed your trip out of the park, taking your kids to London, you know, you might undervalue those accomplishments. You might be like, well, you know, anyone could have done it or there weren't enough people applying for that job and so there was, you know, fewer people to pick from or, you know, it wasn't a real test because the trains all ran on time. You know, there might be things that you were using to undervalue the fact that you did really well and you held it together and you, you know, you had a good result.
冒名顶替综合症的另一个迹象可能是那种觉得自己是个骗子的感觉，你不应该做你正在做的事情，你现在的状态只是运气。也许你觉得人们能看出来，你知道，也许你的皮肤感觉被标记了，人们在背后议论你，那里也可能会潜入一点偏执。当然，我们所知道的是，在职场中晋升的人，有时人们会对你有话要说。他们可能确实在说其中的一些事情，但这并不意味着它是真的。如果你有成功的证据，必须有一个时间、一个点和一个地方，让你开始依靠这些证据，让你开始相信、连接并以某种方式持有
Another sign of imposter syndrome might be that sense that you are a fraud you should not be doing what you're doing it's just luck that you are maybe you feel like people can see it on you you know perhaps your skin feels marked and people are talking about you behind your back there can be a little bit of paranoia creeping in there as well of course what we know about people that rise up through the ranks is that sometimes people will have things to say about you. They might well be saying some of these things, but it doesn't make it true. If you've got evidence of your success, there has to be a time and a point and a place where you begin to lean on those, where you begin to believe, connect and kind of hold
这些成就、这些成功，把它们记在心里，把它们当作脚手架来帮助你，你知道，来帮助你感觉到你确实属于这里，你已经赢得了你的勋章。冒名顶替综合症的另一个迹象可能是过度准备，或者我们称之为拖延，除了能推动你的项目跨越终点线或使其成为现实的事情之外，什么都做。这可能有点像阻碍我们自己，或者因为害怕被评判，或者因为害怕它不够好，因为害怕它会被嘲笑或公开评论，而不想做这件事，准备这件事。所以现在我们已经注意到了症状、迹象，
those achievements, those successes, put them under your belt, use them as scaffolding to help you know, to help you feel that you do belong, that you have earned your stripes. Another sign of imposter syndrome might be over-preparation or perhaps what we call procrastination, kind of doing everything apart from the thing that is going to move your project across the line or get it to a point where it could come to reality. That can be a little bit like getting in our own way or not wanting to do the thing, prepare the thing for fear of judgment or for fear of it not being good enough, for fear of that being then open to ridicule or public comment. So now we have noticed the symptoms, the signs,
或者冒名顶替综合症，我们该怎么做才能控制它，并把它缩小到更易于管理的程度？首先，我们要承认并重构我们的想法和思维。我们只是要在这些想法最初出现时注意到它们。我们可能会发现把它们记下来很有帮助，只是为了在几天或几周内对出现的想法和感受有一个大致的了解。然后我们将鼓励对它们进行重构。试着想象一下，你知道你的好朋友或亲近的人会说什么来帮助你对它们有不同的感觉。如果你觉得某事正在发生，或者应该发生，或者不应该发生，我们将试着把那个声音调小一点。我们将
or the imposter syndrome, what are we going to do about it so that we can take control and have it be shrunk down to a more manageable size? Firstly, we're going to acknowledge and reframe our thoughts and our thinking. We're just going to notice when those thoughts crop up initially. We might find it helpful to note them down just to kind of get a little bit of an overview over the days or the weeks of what kind of thoughts and feelings crop up. We're then going to encourage a reframe of them. Try to imagine what you know your best friend or someone close to you might say to help you feel differently about them. If you have a feeling that something is happening or should be happening or shouldn't be happening, we're going to try and turn down the volume on that a little bit. And we're going
试着寻找更可靠、可预测的外部因素。我们将看事实，而不是感受，因为事实更可衡量。我们还将鼓励你谈论这件事，与你的朋友谈论，与你的主管谈论，给它一些氧气，给它一些空气。因为我们知道，那些躲在潮湿、黑暗中的东西，往往会滋生、变大。因为当我们掌控并谈论它们时，它绝对可以帮助它们减少、缩小，让你掌控局面，并拥有你所需要的所有证据，让你觉得这不是真的，你确实属于这里，你确实值得待在那里，你可以做你正在努力做的事情。我绝对希望并认为，当你给予它所需的空气时间来尊重自己时。你将得到一个信息，那就是
to try to look for more reliable, predictable external factors. We're going to look at facts, not feelings, because facts are more measurable. We're also going to be encouraging you to talk about this, to talk about this with your friends, to talk about this with your supervisors, to give it some oxygen, to give it some air. Because what we know is that things that kind of hide in the damp, in the dark, can have a tendency to breed, to become bigger. Because when we take control and we talk about them, it absolutely can help them to diminish, to shrink, and for you to be in control and to kind of have all the evidence you need to feel like this is not true, that you do belong, that you do deserve to be there, and you can do what you're striving to do. I absolutely hope and think that when you do give that the airtime that you need to to honour yourself. You will be getting the message of just how common
冒名顶替综合症是多么普遍。其他人会分享他们自己的例子，并验证和正常化你的经历，这可能非常重要。解决和克服这种问题的另一种方法是，我们将开始庆祝我们的成功，无论多么微小。即使你真的很享受为你家人或朋友做的晚餐，你也要说，我真的很喜欢这个。就像，我觉得我在这里做得很好。起初可能会感觉很不舒服。但同样，如果你做了一件大事，你知道，如果你提交了一份非常重要的作业，或者你从你投入的事情中得到了一个很好的分数，或者你获得了一笔拨款批准，
imposter syndrome is. Other people will drop in examples of their own and validate and normalise your experiences, which can be so important. Another way of kind of grappling with this and overcoming it is that we're going to begin to celebrate our successes, no matter how small. Even if you're really enjoying a dinner that you've cooked for your family or your friends, you're going to kind of say, I really love this. Like, I think I've done a great job here. It might feel really uncomfortable to begin with. But also, if you've done a big thing, you know, if you have submitted a really important assignment, or you've got a great mark back from something that you've put in, or you've had a grant approved,
或者，你知道，你获得了晋升，或者你从你投入的事情中得到了面试分数，或者你获得了一笔拨款批准，或者你知道你获得了晋升，或者你得到了一个面试机会，我们将庆祝这些步骤，无论它们多么微小或无关紧要，因为它们值得庆祝，它们是我们成功、我们在生活中或职业生涯中取得进步的标志。这并不傲慢，也不吹嘘。你开始积极地、带着同情心、优雅、赞美和钦佩，而不是仅仅带着批评、羞耻和嘲笑来为自己挺身而出，这非常重要。我们的最后一个建议是，我们将发展所谓的成长型思维。我们将减少完美主义，我们将允许错误存在，并知道这是一个非常重要的学习旅程，而且这是有原因的。我们需要能够学习
or, you know, you've got promotion, or you've got an interview mark back from something that you've put in or you've had a grant approved or you know you've got promotion or you've got an interview we're going to celebrate those steps no matter how small or inconsequential they might be because they are worth celebrating they are markers of our success of our progress through whatever life stage or career you find yourself in it isn't arrogant it isn't braggy. It's really important that you begin to show up for yourself positively, with compassion, with grace, with praise and admiration, not just criticism, shame and derision. And our last tip is that we're going to develop what's called a growth mindset. We're going to reduce perfectionism and we're going to allow mistakes in and know that that's a really important learning journey and that that happens for a reason. We need to be able to learn
一路上的挫折，谈论它们，重构它们，并拥有它们。如果不犯一些错误，我们就无法达到职业生涯的高阶段。这是正常的。这是做人的一部分。但当然，我们也需要从中学习。我记得我们正在给房子重做屋顶时，一个实习屋顶工从天花板上掉了下来，我被告知这只会发生一次，因为我们从错误中学习，我们从那种痛苦中学习，我们学会了观察并更加谨慎地对待我们落脚的地方，虽然我希望你不会从屋顶上掉下来，但你在任何工作岗位上所做的事情也是如此。如果你正在经历冒名顶替综合症，请知道你并不孤单。它超级、超级普遍。每个人有时都会面临自我怀疑，但这并不意味着你不配
from setbacks along the way and to talk about them and to reframe them and to own them as well. We don't get to high stages of our career without making some mistakes along the way. That is normal. That is part of being human. But of course, we need to learn from them too. I'm reminded where we were having a roof redone on our house and a trainee roofer fell through the ceiling and I was told it only happens once because we learn from our mistakes we learn from that pain and we learn to kind of look and be more cautious about where we place our feet and whilst I hope you won't fall through a roof, the same is true from what you are doing in whatever job role you are into. If you are experiencing imposter syndrome, please know you're not alone. It is super, super common. Everyone faces self-doubt at times, but that doesn't mean that you are not deserving
拥有你的成功。这并不意味着你不能通过，不能领取200英镑并进入职业生涯的下一个阶段。这里有一个小小的垄断游戏参考。作为一个小小的行动点，你为什么不写下你最近做的三件你认为足够好，或者你感到自豪或高兴发生的事情呢？真正反思一下你为了实现这些事情、把它们装进包里、让它们发生所付出的努力。非常感谢你今天收听。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅、点赞、给我留言，并分享给你认为可能觉得这也有用的人。请务必在我的社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有地方都是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）
of your successes. It doesn't mean that you can't pass go, that you can't collect £200 and go to the next stage of your career. Little monopoly reference there. As a little action point here, why don't you write down three things that you've done recently that you think have been good enough or that you're proud or pleased have happened. Really reflect on what it's taken from you to achieve those things, to get them in the bag, to make them happen. Thanks so much for your time in tuning in today. If you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe, like, drop me a comment and share with anyone you think might find this useful too. Please do come and connect with me on my socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere
并加入我的免费Facebook群组，“有抱负的心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community），这是玛丽安的动力和思维方式课程的独特家园。如果时机成熟，你已经准备好在心理学职业生涯中迈出下一步，也请考虑查看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），你可以以每月仅30英镑的价格加入，没有最低期限。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着在周六上午10点在YouTube上为你带来下一集，并在周一上午6点在任何你获取播客的地方为你带来下一集。保重。那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路
and join my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community, which is the unique home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions. If it is your time and you're ready for the next step in progressing your psychology career, please also do consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join with no minimum term from just £30 a month. Thanks so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to bringing you the next episode on YouTube from 10am on Saturdays and wherever you get your podcast from 6am on Mondays. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
这是玛丽安博士的《有抱负的心理学家》。我叫亚娜，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心
it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist, it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease
一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.